[Music]
and no more Minuteman news I don't know
[Music]
started again and no more Minuteman news
what is bugger flute submitted by the
loco one a startup company has developed
an app to help men prevent premature
ejaculation what a phone app yes how
does that work what exact I can't wait
to find out because I have a friend
don't we all have you had it a friend no
that wasn't what exactly it's premature
jack is it
are you ejaculating before you're fully
erect or you're just each activating
before you want to see what you're jack
ulation is when you eat jack you ate
about a minute into penetration also
there's a definitive time yes that
premature ejaculation is yeah so it's
literally a one minute man like he can
only last a minute and that's why you
have to learn to go down I know it
because sometimes just works me so good
that it takes only two pumps and I'm
done oh my do not too much more place to
I'm sensitive it's too much you know
there used to be a thing we're not used
to be still do where you jerk off before
yeah I think you're gonna have sex
earlier in the day but sometimes say
that doesn't work it does work I tried
it and I was so uninterested yeah
refractory period is that good type of
dress because if it's too loaded it just
it just happens for no reason yeah
you're too excited does this happen to
you be honest come what premature
ejaculator Oh
honest yeah you don't need to worry
about it does it still happen no not
these days
girlfriend but if we haven't done it in
like a month or something and is really
really long I'm super this are you ready
the sound vibration from the clap I'm a
sensitive man I'm sensitive
I hear guys with sleeping bag dicks you
know an uncertain sighs that's the movie
bag yeah last longer they're not as
sensitive but like oh my god they're
more sensitive yeah you would be not so
sensitive because you don't have the
sleeping bag apparently yeah but for
some reason yeah if I have a girlfriend
you know after the first I always take
compliments to you for the first few
times yeah and then once I start dating
them a while then you know I'm easily a
two minutes longer yeah but in the
beginning it's hard well in the
beginning then maybe you can you can use
this thing so you want to impress them
but then it works it backfires yeah yeah
do not mean cream mousse work you you
did it a little grim no but I think it's
a good idea how do you even know about
nothing creams I think does every guy
know but no not make cream for
everything like you don't to get a
tattoos and movie can't take the pants
to put numbing cream on why would you do
that on your day yeah yeah because you
won't you want to be a sensitive so you
could last longer what if you can't get
hard yeah what if you can't get hard
call about timing then probably you get
[ __ ] you know what she jet just use
the condoms that they give that in the
[ __ ] colleges those things are extra
thick you can't feel [ __ ] oh yeah that
is true
might as well do that to me I never want
to have sex again here take this condom
you'll literally feel nothing what's the
point of even doing it at that point all
right well this is really start up here
they it's called virility medical and
they came up with this technology where
it's this little patch are you put in
your Kareem Kareem owner is that the
gucci Greenham the Gooch right I've been
use a scientific term correctly please
Google is that a male tank it's like
this so it looks like oh my god where
does that go this goes here so we're
looking at a bottom part of a man that
area if it gets tickled a lick game over
is this where the tainted love is yup
it's a tainted love right careful right
waiting for girls
I understand where it is I didn't say
chain it's Universal yeah yes it
supposed to be paint [ __ ] tastes like a
Listerine patches [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and
connected to an app on your phone and
what it does is it sends low frequency
electrical currents that contract the
muscles that are responsible for my job
hang on a second did you stop really how
would you girls feel if you guys get him
to like a 69 position and you found this
[ __ ] microchip on this guy's mouth
what have you just said well you didn't
want to say it was for that you said
it's like oh it was an injury that's
even worse I'd rather just I'm trying to
quit smoking girl it hits me harder the
big of G patches better good nicotine
nicotine patch nicotine you shouldn't
make her feel bad smoking diet cancer I
think I was just dying laughter and like
all the sexy mood would be gone you'll
probably just think it was like toilet
paper that he forgot to just clean how
how would you see it though I would just
I don't think I'd wanna 69 we should 69
69 everyone like everyone in this room
visit all the time that was a 2015 kind
of thing I think I think we're just a
little past maybe yeah but yeah so
they're saying that they tested this but
with 20 patients and they had successful
trials and so I just ask one thing can I
jump in a Seinfeld for a second yeah
could you make it a little smaller do we
have to see the whole thing surrounding
it the old computers you know what
though the balls will sag over it and
you won't be able to see it see that
[ __ ] unless your balls really avoid the
69 altogether but what if you get really
lubed in wet nothing just slides off
like a Christmas vacation slug why would
you get the ball or anus well it's just
Lulu
what you know naturally when yeah I mean
they recently had a child so they know
they know it are you doing
congratulations there's a stork
delivered it Oh
do you guys want to see a live
demonstration yeah an informative video
of it oh yeah I wish they showed you how
to put it on this kind of so much get
this guy look at the girl in the back oh
she's like I can't [ __ ] this man can't
beside me ten seconds you shame
all right let's wait a minute long just
praying to Jesus mature ejaculation is
the most form of male sexual dysfunction
it occurs within about one minute of
penetration and results in distress and
frustration for both partners is
developing a perennial skin patch for
climax control the patch carries an
electronic module which delivers
transcutaneous electrical stimulation to
the adjacent nerves and muscles as the
stimulation inhibits the typical
rhythmic muscle contractions ejaculation
is delaying the patches but if you have
to use an erect penis like those so
necessary it could have just been a dick
that's what it works but it's so
unnecessary
just have my shadow of a girl just like
grabbing a heading in Agra face the
realities patch is painless needle and
drug-free Michael's really into this
sorry what jokes he's like where is the
[ __ ] website no I was honestly wanted
to listen and see what this thing does
it it seems it seems I mean like it
could work but it seems it a little bit
of a pain I don't know I feel like
people that get this though they're at
that stage where they tried everything
now it's time to get a robot dick you
know like it's I just want to see a guy
put it on though I think that's the
[ __ ] funny part yeah
well you have to lay on your back and
your [ __ ] you let that [ __ ] go this
way deep when you preview uh when you
pre mature when are you saying man you
see proverbial proverbial you
you've already know he's Fred my bets
like no I'm sure we all have does that
also happen through masturbation like
premature ejaculation of just any type
of stimulation I don't know
we know someone very sweaty that the
jack you laid it from a lap that's cuz
he just might be loaded he was
overloaded tell me why I have a story
called the Belt Parkway and I remember
one time I was we were making out it was
like this I was with this woman and we
were making out in the beginning of the
night and then it got a little but you
know we we sort of knew each other but
not really and then it got a little hot
and heavier than it stopped then we
started making out later and stopped and
then we ended up in her room in New York
City and we're in the bed and with
clothes on like there was a little touch
and we were about thinking about having
sex and it was just like I gotta go to
the bathroom real quick it was just to
that point where it just kept going it
was just too much wow you know just like
and I've never go to the bathroom I go
yeah you know what I'm not sure we
should have sex right now it's the first
time we've made out is that a load on
your belt shut up Wow
I don't know sort of things sort of
happen yeah it was a little embarrassing
so how did you survive you shouldn't be
embarrassed cuz I dream of a time like
that was so turned on throughout the
whole night that my mind my junk was in
a fog was I good it was like on the
verge of just like I don't think I don't
think a girl would be offended though I
know I said the one thing I didn't tell
a whole story
play it off like your I actually said
the wrong thing I'm gonna tell you the
truth because James going
my buddy directed guardians of the
galaxy he always makes fun of me on this
one
nice I said the wrong thing to the girl
what'd you say I said yeah I just yeah
she's what happened I go hi you know I
just decided to just jerk off in the
bathroom why would you say why would you
say this is years ago I didn't know I
wasn't thinking it just came out it
wasn't good improv so there's no it's
that the real question is with you I
know James tells everybody this touring
a while it was I didn't mean to say but
here's what happened David so then my
brother of course started making fun of
me because there's uh there's a highway
in New York called the Belt Parkway a
Parkway in New York so from this day on
he's like hey Belt Parkway what's up I
just unloaded I said the wrong thing I
should have just said I came on myself
but to me that was more embarrassing but
really it's not obviously here we might
be more - that's like she just see that
you like what happened I drink um
sometimes cut this out it's like when
you say something and as you're saying
you're like don't say it don't say it no
it was one of those things no no no I
didn't I'm not gonna try me cool see but
there's four all of those guys out there
that bust the load before you even get
it I actually aspire to be one because I
want to know what it feels like to be so
like at that point of peak where you
can't control it anymore and all a girl
has to do is I want to be there without
struggling is a nuclear way know without
stroking or nothing no and that's
probably cuz I profusely masturbated but
then I don't masturbate a lot
see that's probably why you gotta train
the bike but anyway look like I said if
it happens
you have the bike but you do the trade
[Laughter]
this is my process okay
so a bicycle is everybody jacking off
isn't like riding a bike okay it's it's
a sport and just like any sports you're
gonna you're gonna lose those fine motor
skills and anything if you don't
practice on a frequent basis you think
that's true you've been jerking off for
practice for sex huh no it's just like
dick strengthening those do their kegels
right and then come on man how many
times have you guys stayed away from
jacking off watching pornos for like
months and then you finally watch
something and you're like oh it feels
like the first time it's the same
question first time you had sex that it
lasts long I remember something I'm just
saying it happens I don't remember being
disappointed so yeah yeah I don't think
she was disappointed when I said jerked
off the roof I think she was more
disgusted hope you guys enjoyed that
episode of JK news make sure to stay
connected because we're constantly
updating our social media so follow us
at JK films for Instagram and at JK
films for Twitter to watch more videos
click right over here